Plus d'hommes dans ma famille ont été en prison qu'à l'université.
En fait, pendant que je vous parle, mon père est toujours incarcéré.
Ma mère était adolescente quand elle m'a eu
et nous n'avions pas de sentiments chaleureux envers le gouvernement.
C'est le gouvernement
qui a pratiqué le redlining là où j'ai grandi.
Plein de magasins d'alcools et sans épiceries,
il y avait un manque d'opportunités et une pauvreté concentrée.
Ce sont le gouvernement et les politiciens
qui ont pris la décision
de la guerre contre les drogues et les trois infractions,
qui ont incarcéré bien trop de gens dans notre pays.
Ce sont le gouvernement et les acteurs politiques
qui ont pris la décision des formules de financement des écoles,
qui ont fait que l'école où j'allais recevait moins d'argent par élève
que les écoles dans les zones plus riches.
Rien dans cet historique ne rendait probable mon choix
d'être impliqué en tant qu'acteur gouvernemental.
En même temps, Stockton était un endroit très improbable.
Stockton est ma ville natale, une ville de 320 000 personnes.
Mais historiquement, c'est un endroit
d'où les gens fuient plutôt qu'y retournent.
C'est une ville incroyablement diversifiée.
35% d'Hispaniques, 35% de Blancs,
20% d'Asiatiques, 10% d'Afro-Américains,
le temple sikh le plus vieux d'Amérique du Nord.
Mais quand je me suis porté candidat,
nous étions à l'époque la plus grande ville du pays
à s'être déclarée en faillite.
Quand je me suis porté candidat,
nous avions plus de meurtres par habitant que Chicago.
nous avions un taux de pauvreté de 23%,
nous avons un taux de réussite scolaire de 17%
et un tas de défis et de problèmes hors de portée de quelqu'un de 21 ans.
Après avoir été élu,
j'ai fait ce que je fais quand je suis submergé,
j'ai réalisé que les problèmes de Stockton me dépassaient
et que j'aurais besoin d'une intervention divine.
Alors que je préparais mon premier conseil,
je suis revenu à la sagesse enseignée par ma grand-mère.
Une parabole que nous connaissons tous,
qui constitue le cadre de gouvernance que nous utilisons
pour réinventer Stockton.
A l'école du dimanche, ma grand-mère m'a dit
qu'à un moment, un mec avait demandé à Jésus :
« Qui est mon voisin ?
Qui est mon concitoyen ?
De qui suis-je responsable ? »
Au lieu d'une réponse courte, Jésus a répondu avec une parabole.
Il a dit qu'il y avait un homme en voyage,
marchant sur la route de Jéricho.
Alors qu'il marchait,
il a été battu, laissé sur le bord de la route,
dépouillé de ses vêtements,
on lui avait tout volé et on l'avait laissé pour mort.
Quand un prêtre est passé, a vu l'homme sur le bord de la route,
il a peut-être prononcé une prière en silence,
des espoirs et des prières pour qu'il aille mieux.
Il a peut-être vu l'homme sur le bord de la route
et présumé que Dieu l'avait décrété ainsi,
que cet homme en particulier, ce groupe en particulier,
soit sur le bord de la route, il ne pouvait rien y changer.
Après que le prêtre est passé, un politicien est peut-être passé.
Un politicien de 28 ans, par exemple.
Il a vu l'homme sur le bord de la route, a vu qu'il avait été battu,
a vu que l'homme était une victime de la violence ou fuyait la violence.
Le politicien a décidé : « Vous savez quoi ?
Au lieu d'accueillir cet homme, construisons un mur. »
Le politicien a peut-être dit :
« Cet homme a choisi d'être sur le bord de la route.
S'il se remontait les manches,
même s'il n'avait plus de manches,
et qu'il remontait en selle,
il réussirait et il n'y a rien que je puisse faire. »
Puis finalement, ma grand-mère a dit qu'un bon samaritain est passé,
a vu l'homme sur le bord de la route
et il a vu des siècles de haine
entre les Juifs et les Samaritains,
a regardé et n'a pas vu le reflet de ses peurs,
d'une incertitude économique,
de « que va-t-il m'arriver car les choses changent ».
Il a regardé et il a vu son propre reflet.
Il a vu son voisin, il a vu leur humanité commune.
Il ne s'est pas contenté de voir, il a agi,
m'a dit ma grand-mère.
Il a posé un genou à terre,
s'est assuré que l'homme allait bien
et, de ce que j'ai entendu dire, lui a offert une belle chambre d'hôtel.
(Rires)
En me préparant à gouverner,
j'ai réalisé qu'étant donnée la diversité de Stockton,
la première étape pour apporter du changement
serait de répondre à nouveau à la même question :
qui est notre voisin ?
Et réaliser que notre destin en tant que ville
était lié à tout le monde.
En particulier ceux qui sont laissés sur le bord de la route.
Mais j'ai ensuite réalisé que l'altruisme n'est pas de la justice,
que les gestes d'empathie ne sont pas de la justice,
qu'être un bon voisin est nécessaire mais n'est pas suffisant
et qu'il fallait faire plus.
En considérant l'histoire,
j'ai réalisé que la route pour Jéricho avait un surnom.
On l'appelait « le chemin sanglant »,
« l'ascension du rouge »
car la route est structurée pour la violence.
La route de Jéricho est étroite, propice aux embuscades.
Un homme sur le bord de la route n'était pas anormal,
n'était pas étrange.
C'est quelque chose qui était structuré pour arriver,
qui était censé arriver.
Johan Galtung, un théoricien de la paix,
parle de violence structurelle dans notre société.
Il a dit : « La violence structurelle est l'altération évitable
de besoins humains fondamentaux. »
Le Dr Paul Farmer parle de violence structurelle
et parle de comment
nos institutions, nos politiques, notre culture
mènent à des aboutissements avantageant certains et désavantageant d'autres.
Puis j'ai réalisé que, comme la route de Jéricho,
de bien des façons, Stockton et notre société
avaient été structurées pour ce dont nous nous plaignons.
Nous ne devrions pas être surpris
de voir que les enfants pauvres ne réussissent pas à l'école,
de voir les écarts de richesse par race et par ethnie,
de voir des disparités salariales entre les genres,
car c'est, historiquement,
ce que notre société a été structurée à faire
et elle fonctionne en conséquence.
(Applaudissements)
En tenant compte de cette sagesse,
je me suis relevé les manches et mis au travail.
Voici trois histoires courtes que je veux partager
qui montrent que nous n'avons pas tout résolu,
nous n'y sommes pas encore,
mais nous allons dans la bonne direction.
La première histoire est au sujet du voisin.
En tant que conseiller municipal,
je travaillais avec l'un des membres les plus conservateurs de la communauté
pour ouvrir une clinique pour les gens sans papiers
dans le sud de la ville et j'adorais cela.
Alors que nous ouvrions la clinique,
nous avions une résolution à signer
et il m'a montré un cadeau.
C'était une broche d'affiliation à vie à un programme républicain.
(Rires)
Je ne lui ai pas demandé
ce qu'il avait fait pour mériter ce cadeau.
Quel pacte de sang -- j'ignorais comment il l'avait eu.
Mais je l'ai regardé et j'ai dit :
« Comment travaillons-nous ensemble pour ouvrir une clinique,
pour offrir des soins de santé gratuits à des gens sans papiers
et vous êtes membre à vie d'un programme républicain ? »
Il m'a regardé et a dit :
« Conseiller Tubbs, c'est pour mes voisins. »
Il est un excellent exemple de ce que c'est
que d'être un bon voisin, tout du moins dans ce cas-là.
Les voleurs.
Après quatre ans au conseil municipal, j'ai brigué la mairie,
réalisant qu'être conseiller à mi-temps n'était pas assez
pour promulguer les changements structurels à Stockton
et j'en suis venu à cette conclusion en considérant les données.
Mon ancien quartier, où j'ai grandi,
est à 10 minutes d'un quartier plus aisé.
Et 10 minutes dans une même ville,
la différence entre les codes postaux 95205 et 95219,
en termes d'espérance de vie, ce sont 10 ans.
Dix minutes, sept kilomètres,
dix ans de différence dans l'espérance de vie
et non pas du fait des choix que les gens font.
Personne ne vit par choix dans une communauté peu sûre
où on ne peut pas faire de sport.
Personne n'a choisi de mettre plus de magasins d'alcool que d’épiceries.
Personne n'a choisi cela, mais c'est la réalité.
J'ai réalisé que pour promulguer le changement structurel souhaité,
où entre ces codes postaux,
il y a 30% de différence dans le taux de chômage,
il y a une différence de revenus de 75 000 dollars par ans,
être conseiller n'allait pas être suffisant.
Alors j'ai décidé de briguer la mairie.
En tant que maire, nous nous sommes concentrés sur les voleurs et la route.
A Stockton, comme je l'ai dit,
nous avons historiquement eu des crimes violents.
C'est pour cela que j'ai décidé de briguer la mairie.
Mon premier rôle de maire a été d'aider notre communauté
à nous voir, nous, nos voisins,
pas que chez les gens victimisés par la violence
mais aussi chez les contrevenants.
Nous avons réalisé que ceux imposant de la douleur dans notre société,
ceux qui commettent des homicides et contribuent à la violence armée
sont souvent eux-mêmes des victimes.
Ils ont connu des traumatismes, se sont fait tirer dessus,
connaissent des gens sur qui on a tiré.
Cela n'excuse pas leur comportement mais aide à l'expliquer
et, en tant que communauté, nous devons nous voir en eux.
Eux aussi sont nos voisins.
Les trois dernières années --
(Applaudissements)
Depuis trois ans, nous travaillons sur deux stratégies :
un cessez-le-feu et l'avancée de la paix,
nous accordons beaucoup d'attention et d'amour à ces gens,
des services sociaux, des opportunités, des détatouages,
parfois même de l'argent liquide :
un cadeau des forces de l'ordre.
L'année dernière, nous avons observé une diminution des homicides de 40%
et une réduction de 30% des crimes violents.
(Applaudissements)
Maintenant, la route.
J'ai dit que ma communauté avait un taux de pauvreté de 23%.
Étant quelqu'un issu de la pauvreté, j'en fais une affaire personnelle.
J'ai décidé de ne pas seulement établir un programme
ou de faire quelque chose tournant autour du pot,
mais nous allions remettre en question la structure
qui entraîne de la pauvreté.
Depuis février, nous avons lancé une démonstration du revenu de base
où, pendant les 18 prochains mois,
dans un projet pilote, 130 familles choisies au hasard
et vivant dans des quartiers sous le revenu médian de la ville,
reçoivent 500 dollars par mois.
Nous faisons cela pour plusieurs raisons.
Car nous avons réalisé
que structurellement, une chose clochait en Amérique,
quand un Américain sur deux n'a pas 400 dollars pour une urgence.
Car nous avons réalisé que structurellement, une chose clochait
quand les salaires n'avaient augmenté que de 6% entre 1979 et 2013.
quand les gens ayant deux ou trois emplois,
effectuant le travail dont personne ne veut,
ne peuvent pas payer le minimum vital : le loyer,
l'électricité, les soins de santé et la garde des enfants.
(Applaudissements)
Je dirais à nouveau que nous avons de vrais problèmes à Stockton.
J'ai actuellement des mails d'électeurs sur le problème de sans-abrisme,
sur certains des crimes violents que nous connaissons.
Je dirais qu'en tant que société, il serait sage d'en revenir
à ces vieilles histoires bibliques apprises en grandissant
et de comprendre
que nous devons nous voir comme des voisins,
que quelqu'un de différent de nous
ne devrait pas refléter nos peurs, nos anxiétés, nos insécurités,
les préjugés qu'on nous a appris, mais nous devrions nous y voir.
Nous devrions voir notre humanité commune.
Car je pense qu'ainsi,
nous pouvons entreprendre l'importante restructuration de la route.
Je comprends que certains qui écoutent disent :
« Maire Tubbs, vous parlez de violence et d'autres soucis structurels,
mais vous êtes sur scène.
Les structures ne sont pas si terribles
si vous avez pu grandir dans la pauvreté,
avoir un père en prison, aller à Stanford,
travailler à la Maison-Blanche et devenir maire. »
Je répondrais en disant que le terme pour cela est l'exceptionnalisme.
Nous reconnaissons qu'il est exceptionnel pour les gens d'échapper aux structures.
Par notre langage même,
nous comprenons que ce que nous voyons dans notre monde est conçu ainsi.
Je crois que pour notre tâche, en tant participants à TED,
en tant que personnes bonnes, justes et morales,
est de réaliser le dur labeur nécessaire,
pas seulement de nous tendre la main en tant que voisins,
mais d'utiliser nos mains pour restructurer notre route,
une route qui, dans ce pays, est ancrée dans la suprématie blanche.
Une route qui, dans ce pays, est ancrée dans la misogynie.
Une route qui ne va pas à beaucoup trop de gens.
Je crois qu'aujourd'hui, demain et en 2020,
nous avons une chance de changer cela.
Alors que je m'approche de ma conclusion,
j'ai commencé par une histoire d'il y a neuf ans
et finirai avec une autre.
Après le meurtre de mon cousin,
j'ai eu la chance de participer à quelques Freedom Rides
avec certains des premiers activistes.
Ils m'ont beaucoup appris sur la restructuration de la route.
Un gars en particulier, Bob Singleton, m'a posé une question
avec laquelle je vais vous quitter.
Nous allions à Anniston, dans l'Alabama, et il a dit : « Michael ? »
et j'ai dit : « Oui, Monsieur. »
Il a dit : « J'ai été arrêté le 4 août 1961.
Pourquoi ce jour est-il important ? »
J'ai dit : « Vous avez été arrêté,
si ce n'avez pas été le cas, nous ne serions pas dans ce bus
et par conséquent, nous ne jouirions pas de nos droits. »
Il a levé les yeux au ciel et a dit : « Non, fiston.
C'est le jour de la naissance de Barack Obama. »
Puis il a dit qu'il ignorait que le choix qu'il ferait
pour restructurer la route
ouvrirait la voie
pour qu'un enfant né en tant que citoyen de deuxième classe,
qui ne pourrait même pas avoir un verre d'eau dans un bar,
aurait la chance, 50 ans plus tard, d'être président.
Puis il m'a regardé et a dit :
« Qu'es-tu prêt à faire aujourd'hui
pour que dans 50 ans,
un enfant ait la chance d'être président ? »
TED, je crois que c'est la question à laquelle nous faisons face.
Nous savons qu'il y a un problème.
Ce que nous avons vu récemment n'est pas anormal
mais c'est le reflet d'un système qui a été structuré
pour produire des résultats aussi fous.
Mais je pense que c'est une opportunité.
Car ces structures dont nous héritons ne sont pas divines
mais humaines et découlent de choix politiques,
sont créées par des politiciens et approuvées par des électeurs.
Nous avons la chance et la formidable opportunité
d'y faire quelque chose.
Ma question est : que sommes-nous prêts à faire aujourd'hui
pour qu'un enfant né aujourd'hui, dans 50 ans,
ne soit pas dans une société ancrée dans la suprématie blanche,
ne soit pas dans une société criblée de misogynie,
ne soit pas dans une société criblée d'homophobie, de transphobie,
d'antisémitisme, d'islamophobie et de capacitisme
et toutes les phobies et -ismes ?
Que sommes-nous prêts à faire aujourd'hui
pour que dans 50 ans,
nous ayons une route dans notre société qui soit structurée
pour refléter ce que nous tenons pour évident ?
Pour que tous les hommes, toutes les femmes,
mêmes toutes les personnes transgenres,
naissent égaux
et soient dotés par notre Créateur de certains droits inaliénables
y compris le droit à la vie, la liberté et la poursuite du bonheur ?
Merci.
(Applaudissements)